[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: All right.
Let's look at this schedule.
So we're going to do the second
of two applications in trade
today, focusing on the
US and data issues.
So that's where we are
in terms of the schedule.
In terms of the
reading list, we're,
again, down to lecture 15.
There's two papers
that are starred here.
And I have a few slides
on each of these--
one, this Raj Chetty
et al paper having
to do with the
impact of COVID-19.
And you'll see today
how that fits in to what
we're trying to accomplish.
And relatedly is this
paper by Scott Baker
and co-authors, again, on
the impact of the virus.
So you know that I am very
conservative about starring
material.
But, today, those two
things are starred and given
important obvious importance
surrounding us of this topic.
You might find them
particularly interesting,
and I'll introduce
that work today.
And also, previous lecture,
there were two starred papers
as well, including Dawkins,
that we didn't cover in class.
So that's the reading list.
And then, as usual,
we can review
a bit what we did last time,
gains and losses from trade.
So it's lecture 14.
So the first one I earmarked--
"There are two key features
that distinguish households even
within the same village."
And I wrote this.
"Pick one of these and be able
to tell a classmate about it."
Try to tell "a compelling story
about how households differ."
Imagine if you want to be a
reporter for the news diving
into a community
and interviewing
various types of households.
So let me get
volunteers on this.
Two key features.
We covered two key features.
I'm asking you to pick one.
AUDIENCE: I think the
first one is talent.
And the second one--
I think maybe it's a
initial fixed assets, which
can determine your job.
For example, if your
initial asset is low,
maybe you are a wage earner.
And if your initial
fixed asset is large,
you own, like, a business.
And for talent, what we
have discussed is that--
this is more related
to the sector part.
I remember that if we take all
the capital and labor which
is not related to talent,
and we get the talent,
and we have sector
average talent,
and if we also
exclude that part,
and we have household-specific
talent, which will distinguish
households between each other.
And this talent will also
be related to the jobs
that the households have.
And I remember there is a table
in the stats which have, like,
livestock and something.
Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Perfect answer.
That's really terrific.
It's hard to add to that.
Yeah.
In a village, you
have rich people
and poor people distinguished
by assets, or even
real, tangible assets.
And you've got people
that differ in talent.
The talent is something
you don't see directly
that you can back it out from
how much they're producing,
controlling for the
capital and labor
that they utilize in production.
And so there was
a big dispersion
in that productivity level
across different households.
Great answer.
Thank you.
Next up, "Follow the lines
of national level product
and income accounts,"
so-called NIPA, national income
and product accounts.
Essentially, this
question is saying,
where does GDP come from?
What is it, and how
do we measure it?
And, in particular, how can
we use the household income
account to get to these numbers?
And today I'm in the mood
just to take volunteers.
So would someone like
to take a crack at--
excuse me-- at that one?
AUDIENCE: I know
that GDP is the--
it's the sum of the final
goods that are sold.
So it doesn't
include anything that
is going to be used as an input
for producing something else.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's right.
So GDP is-- we have to
avoid double counting.
So if a firm is
producing something
using capital and
labor and so on,
and it sells that
to another firm,
that becomes an input
in the other firm.
So the danger is
double counting what
is the input in one firm as
the output in the other one.
So what you're referring
to is value added.
So we take output, and
we subtract off payments
to factors--
sorry, subtract off
intermediate goods.
And the rest of it is net
product being produced.
Another way to put that is
that, quote, "net product"
at the level of
a given household
should add up to
factor payments,
so namely, wages paid, interest
on capital, rent or interest
if borrowed, and so on.
So I think the hard part of
this question, given that you--
thank you for
volunteering, Armando--
is it's hard to
describe in words
or even remember the details
of the financial accounts.
We started in the lecture
with the income statement
of the household, which
had revenues and costs.
And then we added and subtracted
across the various line items
to produce what
we called product.
So you can go back
and review that.
And that's kind of the harder
part to put into words.
I'm not even doing
that well myself.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a quick question?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Can you give us some
specific details
about the difference between
the inventories and imports?
Sometimes, maybe inventories--
we calculate the inventories
when we calculate the NIPA.
But we subtract the inputs.
But sometimes we-- maybe
some inventories could be
the inputs in the next period.
In this period,
we buy something,
and we do not use them.
And so they are not imports.
But in the next period,
they would be the inputs.
Then, in the next period,
when we recalculate the NIPA,
we should subtract this part.
We should subtract
these inventories.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
So you've almost
given the answer.
We want to keep track of the
difference between buying
and holding versus using.
So in the productions, the
income statement and so on,
we have the cost of
producing something.
So if they take something
out of inventory
or buy it on the market,
we value it at the cost
and have it as part of
the cost of production.
So that's kind of
the flow input.
Now, if they bought
something on the market
but didn't utilize it
yet, as in your example,
then they accumulate
it as inventory.
And that part is an asset that
appears on the balance sheet.
So there is a relation
here between the stocks
and the flows.
And indeed, in the Thai
data, we have all kinds
of inventory accounts.
We have the rice
that they produced
and didn't actually sell.
So we have an output
inventory account.
We have fertilizer
that they buy,
but they haven't put
on the field yet.
So that's an input
inventory account.
And those things
are not trivial.
But the inventory
per se is a way
of carrying value over time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: You're welcome.
OK.
"How much do villages
differ from one another
in terms of production."
And, in particular, "Do villages
vary in the shares of payments
to factors of production?"
And, again, today, I'm
just taking volunteers.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I can take this one.
So I think we had that the ones
that were near the urban area--
I think that was the center--
tended to have a lot more
output than the ones that
were in the Northeast, the more
rural and farming villages,
whereas the central
was more manufacturing.
And we saw this
difference, I guess,
not only in the value
of their output,
but also in where
their income went to.
So I think we had that more went
to capital in the manufacturing
center areas, and more went
to wages in the rural farming
areas.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
That's right.
We had wages being relatively
low where labor is abundant.
That's in the agricultural
northeast part of the country.
And if you look at the share--
well, it's a bit tricky because
there's a lot of laborers,
but the wage is low.
So you have to multiply
price times quantity.
And then you get the
share of total income
in the village which is
attributable to labor.
But you're right
about the factor
prices and also about
the difference in levels.
Those villages in
regions near Bangkok
have very high output
levels, or GDP levels,
relative to villages
in the Northeast.
OK.
Anyway, in the Northeast,
despite the lower wages,
the share of labor and
income was higher than
in the central region.
And then I'll just ask about
the balance of payments.
Does someone remember what
the balance of payments
is for a village or a country?
AUDIENCE: Would that just
be the various balances of--
no, that would just
be the balance sheet.
No.
It's not [INAUDIBLE]
the accumulated
assets and liabilities of
everyone added together?
Is that it?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It
has to do with trade.
AUDIENCE: Is it a
current account?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's just
the sum of the trade balance
and net income transfers.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's right.
So the balance of payments is
like the current account, which
is the sum of the trade
balance, exports minus imports,
plus factor payments coming from
abroad-- incoming remittances
and gifts and so on.
So those are the two
components of the flows
on the left-hand side of the
so-called balance equation,
balance of payments equation.
What's on the right hand side?
The two sides add up and
are equal to each other.
What happens if a village
is exporting a lot
and importing relatively little?
Where's the money going?
AUDIENCE: A financial account?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, it's
in the financial account.
So, essentially, they're
accumulating deposits
in commercial banks
outside the village
or accumulating currency as cash
or, essentially, accumulating
claims on foreigners.
So if you export a
lot and import little,
you have an advantage.
What did you do with the money?
You've got to put it somewhere.
Or you could have been
indebted externally,
and then you're going to
repay some of that debt.
So the claims that
foreigners have on you
would be diminished.
All right.
So we're going to revisit
some of these concepts today.
So let's start doing that.
So lecture today, 15, data
and policy in the US--
and I've mentioned this
before as motivation,
but here we actually
have the slides--
something called the China shock
from the standpoint of the US.
And it has to do with
international trade
and the welfare
gains and losses.
So economists argue that
trade is a good thing,
that it improves welfare.
But we know from
two lectures now--
the two-by-two theory lecture
as well as the Thai lecture--
that trade may
redistribute income.
The idea would be
that the winners
gain more than the losers lose.
So, effectively, if you were
to try to add it all up,
it may appear somehow that
free trade is a good thing.
But, beneath the surface,
there are winners and losers
from increasing
foreign competition.
In some respects, this slide
is an introduction to something
we're going to do two or
three lectures from now, which
is to talk about aggregation.
When we draw those
pictures, we look
like we have a production
possibilities frontier.
We have one consumer
with indifference curves.
It looks like, as you move
from autarky to free trade,
the consumer is better off.
But that picture is
implicitly assuming
that we can aggregate
households up
so that it appears that
there's just one representative
household.
In fact, beneath the surface,
income is getting redistributed
and some people will
be losing from trade.
So the movement from
autarky to free trade
is not necessarily Pareto
improving unless you
compensate the losers.
So here's the Heckscher-Ohlin
theorem again.
"Owners of a country's abundant
factors gain from trade,
but owners of a country's
scarce factors lose."
So you may remember,
if the country is
abundant in one of the factors,
then the price of that factor
tends to be low in autarky.
And that's good for
producing, especially
for sectors that are relatively
intensive in that factor.
So when you open the
country up for trade,
that low price will be
attractive to foreigners.
The country will be exporting.
And that, a la
Stolper-Samuelson,
will raise the price of the
factor that's relatively
intensive in production.
But the flip side is the other
factor, the scarce factor,
will be losing as a
result of free trade.
The US is abundant
in skilled labor.
Low-skilled labor is
relatively scarce,
although not
nonexistent, obviously.
So when the US opens up to
trade with Mexico and China
and so on, low-skilled workers
in the US are made worse off.
And I can't help but say
we're in the midst of the US
elections, and these
are big issues.
What happened in the Midwest
in Michigan, Wisconsin,
Pennsylvania, Ohio, and so on,
referred to as the Rust Belt--
means they were doing a lot
of manufacturing and so on.
And the view is that
many of the households
were hurt by the rise of trade.
China in particular emerged
as a great international power
and made very
clear the relevance
of Heckscher-Ohlin and
Stolper-Samuelson and so on.
Actually, the slide
is a bit of a rambling
because it didn't
look, for a long time,
as if people were
being hurt from trade
and people were
reconsidering the consensus.
But now we went right back
to the original underpinnings
of the theory.
In particular, these trade
shocks that originate in China
have impacted industries,
plants, and local labor markets
across the US.
I'll show you a
picture momentarily.
So we want to estimate
the gains from trade.
We also want to
document the losses that
also arise under free trade.
And we want to quantify who's
winning and who's losing.
That was the theme
of the Thai lecture
last time, to distinguish
labor from capital,
one village from another,
changing the prices,
the relative prices of goods.
And we did counterfactuals--
what if they hadn't
become more liberal,
what if we imposed a tax
on imports, and so on.
And we were documenting
how the incidents could
be good or bad,
depending on wealth
and talent of the households.
So we're going to
try to do something
like that momentarily
for the US.
Here is a picture of China--
share of world
manufacturing value added.
We talked about value added a
minute ago, the blue line going
up steadily over the decades--
20 years approximately--
and China's share of world
manufacturing exports.
So not only are
they producing more,
they're exporting it,
also on the steady rise.
And here's a picture of
the US current account.
We reviewed the definition
of this just a moment ago,
the trade balance plus
incoming remittances.
The current account
in the US is negative
and got increasingly negative
at exactly the same time
that China's current
account was positive
and increasing,
peaking, say, in 2005.
Now, this picture probably
includes the overall US current
account, not only with China,
but with other countries,
and likewise for China.
But for all the world, it
looks very bilateral here.
Obviously, a big part
of what's happening
to the trade balance
in the US has
to do with China,
and vice versa.
And then here's a picture
of the US by state.
And this is from that Autor,
Dorn, and Hanson reference
about four slides ago.
So they looked at the
composition of Chinese imports
into the US by sector
and looked at where
those goods had been produced
previously by county in the US.
And these dark
areas are the areas
that are most
vulnerable in the sense
that they had been
producing things that
are now imported from China.
That doesn't mean in that state.
It means for the US in general.
So Chinese imports are
bought by consumers
all over the United
States, which
means that a state, like a big
chunk of Tennessee, if you can
see it there, which had
been producing manufactured
goods now being
imported from China,
itself would be exporting less
to other states in the United
States because
it's not producing.
Those other states are buying
it directly from China.
Anyway, it's kind of spotty.
But you can see it's
certainly not universal.
And here's a measure of the
current account, the trade
balances plus net remittances.
But this treats a state
in the United States
as a whole country.
Or another way to
put it-- it treats
the states in the
United States the way
we were considering
villages in Thailand.
So you can see here that the
current account, the scale
that's down here, is positive.
So these are net
exporting states.
And the red, dark orange
colors are, quote,
"net importing" states.
So here's a review of
those equations again.
The current account consists
of the trade balance
and net incoming
transfers of income.
The trade balance is
itself the difference
between exports and imports.
Net income transfers consist of
private and public transfers.
So in the US, for example,
there's a lot of taxes
and a lot of welfare programs.
So, actually, a big part
of the state's income
is attributable to
net public transfers.
But that's not the only
source of transfers.
There are gifts and
remittances across states.
Now, how does one get at that?
Well, there's gross state income
versus gross state product.
The product we talked
about earlier--
10 minutes ago-- means that
it is produced in the state,
hiring capital and
labor and so on.
But their gross state income
on the income statement
of households would
include income
that they earned in other states
or that other household members
earned in other states and sent
back home to the home state.
Fortunately, the US measures--
the Bureau of Economic Analysis
measures both gross state
income and gross state product.
We take the difference of those,
and we have net transfers.
And then, finally,
the current account,
which is, again the trade
balance and net income
transfers on the
left, is balanced
by claims on other states.
So this is what I asked about.
Now, I'm going to show you
a lot of data momentarily.
But this equation is kind
of making some assumptions.
Namely, it's assuming
that the financial part
of the adjustment has to do with
the transection of the given
state with other states--
for example, trading in
stocks and bonds and so on.
So that's the part we want.
What we don't want is state
investment in the capital stock
or housing investment,
because those
are internal within the state.
So to get the change on
claims in foreigners,
we take the change in
net worth, and then
subtract off how
much of that shows up
as increased investment
in capital and housing,
and assume the rest of it is
an increase in financial claims
on foreign--
I want to say foreign
states, on other states.
And we'll see how well
this works out momentarily.
So what data?
Well, in the US, you have to be
diligent and creative to begin
to measure the
various components.
So I won't dwell on this.
But, fortunately, there is
something called the commodity
flow survey, which measures
trade flows across states
in the United States,
interstate trade.
The growth state
income and product
comes from BEA
regional accounts,
as does public transfers.
These measures incidence
of the China shock,
I already showed you from
Autor, Dorn, and Hanson.
And we have those from David.
Housing stock comes from
American Community Survey.
We have a price index.
The socks and bonds
transactions are tough to get.
But we have indirect
access to IRS data
where people report
dividends and so on.
And you can kind of back
out what their ownership
is of the assets from how
much interest earnings
and so on that they report.
The capital stock
is also hard to get.
I'm not saying much about it.
Household debt is pretty well
measured in the New York Fed
CCP, Consumer Credit Panel,
which is Equifax credit
card-type data.
So what is this not?
It's not like Thailand.
And I keep coming back to this.
It's not like we're on
the ground measuring
the income statement, the
balance sheet, cash flow and so
on.
Instead, we have to use
the best available data
in the US, which is
different variables coming
from different sources.
Although the accounting
equations should still be true,
the way that we're measuring
the variables is different.
So what's the impact
of the China shock?
We use the accounting identity
I just showed you, technically
called "seemingly
unrelated regressions,"
we could regress the trade
balance on the China shock.
We can regress gifts and
remittances on the China shock.
If that accounting
identity is true,
there is some relationship
across those seemingly
separately estimated
regressions.
And so this technique is a
way to do it jointly and take
into account the
accounting identity.
So we take, say--
let me skip down
here-- a 10-year difference.
You can think of
this conceptually
as comparing states hit by the
Chinese shock, states which
have not been hit
by the China shock,
and then comparing what's going
on with their trade balance.
The impact on the trade
balance is negative.
That is to say it's
an adverse shock.
The impact on the current
account is negative--
also an adverse shock.
Impact on transfers
is positive, but not
enough to overcome the
difference in the trade
balance.
And we can break
it down further.
Exports-- a state specialized
in manufactured goods now
competing with China, exports
of that state to other states
goes down.
Imports don't seem
to move very much.
They're not importing less.
Public transfers, ironically,
over a 10-year period,
don't move much.
But private transfers, quite
interestingly, are positive.
So this is a pretty new finding.
We haven't published it yet.
But it should remind you
a little bit about gift
giving in Thai villages.
We talked about them
helping each other out
from various shocks.
These states, obviously,
quote unquote,
"help each other
out" in the sense
that they get incoming
gifts and remittances
and factor payments
precisely when they need it
when they're in trouble
because they've been hit
by a long-term adverse shock.
So that's kind of the, quote
unquote, "left-hand side"
of the equation.
Now we can turn to
the right-hand side,
which is adjustments in
physical and financial capital.
And we don't find much.
Housing actually went up,
which is counterintuitive.
And the rest of the
variables are insignificant.
Now, this violates the
accounting identity.
Something on the right-hand
side has to move.
But, because we've
been using data
from all these
different sources,
as well as assuming that we have
a way of measuring decreased
claims on other states, we're
just not doing good enough.
It's not a comment
on our techniques.
It's a comment on both the
data sources as well as
this assumption.
And I'll keep
coming back to that.
In particular, how do we measure
wealth and income in the US?
Our measure of wealth
on the right-hand side
isn't working very well.
It is supposed to be aggregated
up at the state level.
But, within a state,
there's arguably a lot
of heterogeneity,
which is kind of why
we reviewed what way villages
differ from one another
and households within villages
differ from one another.
And surely within
a state in the US,
you see rich people
and poor people.
You see a lot of
different wealth groups.
So the low-wealth
group would correspond
with low-wealth workers
who rely on wages,
and hopefully, on pensions,
versus the higher-wealth people
within a state which
typically have income
from their business.
So when we aggregate
up to the whole state,
we're not able to
make this distinction.
So that's one potential problem.
Some households'
financial assets
are going in one
direction as they're
benefited, others going
in the opposite direction
as they're harmed.
And we take the net difference,
and we're having trouble
finding something.
That's one plausible
explanation.
The other is the way the data
are collected to begin with.
The Federal Reserve is
constructing Flow of Funds,
changing the balance
sheet, and using
a survey called the Survey
of Consumer Finances.
And it does a really
wonderful job.
These are really
important measurements.
People use the Flow of Funds and
the Survey of Consumer Finances
all the time for
US data analysis,
although it's not really
available at a regional level,
and certainly not at
the level of states.
They don't gather it that way,
and they won't release it.
Believe me, I've tried.
The flip side are the
flows from the Bureau
of Economic Analysis.
And they do a great job,
too, as I've already
said, measuring
income and product,
not only at the state level, but
at the level of municipalities
and centers,
districts, and so on.
The problem is these
different agencies
are doing a good job with
the thing under their domain.
But they have no--
the Federal Reserve is not
collecting income data,
and the BEA is not collecting
asset or wealth data.
So the wealth changes
and the income changes
are not consistent
with one another.
They're not using the logic
of the accounting identities
that we've been emphasizing.
What identity?
Namely, when you have,
say, positive savings--
that's a flow-- what are
they doing with that saving?
That should show up
as a change in wealth,
a change in real or financial
assets in the balance sheet,
at least adjusting
for capital gains.
The balance sheet can go up
or down with the stock market.
You don't want that.
So you take out those
price movements,
and you're left with real
balance sheet items that
have to move in the sense
of an accounting identity
with savings.
But they don't, in the
data, because the data
aren't measured through the
lens of the accounting identity.
Unlike what we showed
you for Thailand,
where we collected
the data at the level
of individual
households and firms,
where we had the income,
the balance sheet,
and so on for each one of them,
the income and balance sheet
have to be consistent
with one another.
In the US, we have these
well-known surveys.
I've already mentioned the
Survey of Consumer Finances
from the Federal Reserve Board.
We have the Consumer Expenditure
Survey, the Panel Study
of Income Dynamics, and others.
So I'm showing you a
balance sheet constructed
by each one of these surveys.
These items should
start to seem familiar.
You've got current assets--
namely cash, bank accounts,
certificates of deposit,
and so on.
So, say, the median level--
$422,000 depending
on the survey--
it's only $226,000 in the
survey of consumer finances.
It's $600,000-- the
different surveys
measure different things.
So that's one problem.
But also, we have
physical investments
down here, business assets,
housing assets, and so on.
So this should be reminding
you of the balance
sheets for the Thai households.
After all, the concept of a
balance sheet is quite general.
It's just a matter of
where you're applying it.
However, this is not one
particular household.
This is the median
or average level,
that sort of synthesized
or synthetic balance
sheet that's created for
each and all of these surveys
individually.
And you can get the
income statement.
An aggregate version from the
PSID, the Consumer Expenditure
Survey, and so on--
median income in the US,
roughly $67,000, $65,000,
$83,000, $70,000 et cetera,
coming from labor income,
production income, other income,
including interest dividends,
government transfers.
And we have expenditures.
So expenditures would not only
be depreciation and so on.
But it would include taxes.
And the way we do the
accounting in Thailand,
we have consumption over here.
So, basically,
that's an outflow.
We had net profits taking
revenue minus expenses.
And from the net profits,
if it were positive,
we would have savings
and consumption.
So consumption is not included.
That's why it's in red here.
But it is in the
Statement of Cash Flows.
And here's the
Statement of Cash Flows
for each one of those surveys--
cash flow from
production, cash flow
from consumption,
from investment,
cash flow from financing.
We introduced a
cash flow statement
way back when we
talked about Bitcoin.
We had transfer of
Bitcoin accounts.
I made the point that both the
balance sheet and the cash flow
were being represented
in the same ledger.
You had to own it
before you could
buy it-- use it to buy things.
Relatedly, the change in cash
flow in Bitcoin should be--
if it's outgoing, should be
associated with a decrease
in the ownership of the coin.
Or more generally, in
the accounting sense,
the change in cash in the
statement of cash flow
should be the same
as the change in cash
holding in the balance sheet.
It seems pretty natural.
And if you collect the data from
scratch, each entity, one at
a time, you can run
this check and make
sure it's true if you're using
the accounting framework.
If not, then you
did something wrong,
and you have to start over.
The US data are not
collected in that way.
Nobody ever ran this check.
So I did it with
Scott Schuh and Chris.
And here you can see
a big discrepancy
between the change
in the cash flow
from the statement of cash
flow and the change in cash
as measured on the change
in the balance sheet.
How big are these numbers?
Well, the percent
normalized by current assets
is anywhere from 16 to 37%.
It's huge.
In other words,
something is wrong.
The flows aren't
measured properly,
or the assets are not
measured properly.
Does it really matter?
Can we wave our hands.
Well, we tried to use
the data that we have.
But we could be off by as much
as 37% on the balance sheet.
So this is the sad state
of affairs for US data.
Although I must say each
one of these surveys
is really fantastic,
it was never
designed with the accounting
framework in mind.
And they're very
good at measuring
what they intended to do.
But, on the other hand,
they never ran this check.
So the notion that the
change in the balance
sheet and the income statement
ought to be consistent
is not new.
It comes with the accounts.
And there is something in the
US called integrated macro
accounts, which is exactly what
it is-- accounts integrated
with each other.
So this unusual cooperation
between the Federal Reserve
Board and the BEA tried to
pool the data that each has,
that each is good at collecting.
But they didn't change the way
they're collecting the data.
So there's an errors
and omission line
that shows up in the accounts,
which is the way they reconcile
the two systems together.
And, again, that error
and omissions line
is sometimes quite substantial.
Here's a picture for these
integrated financial accounts,
which is really a review
of what you already know.
You start with production.
And then you have inputs,
outputs, profits, and so on,
producing income and savings,
if they didn't eat everything.
The savings has to
show up somewhere.
It's showing up in physical
fixed inputs, capital inputs,
or it's showing up in financial
inputs, net lending or asset
acquisition if positive,
or a decrease in borrowing,
assuming that profits
over here were positive.
Then you adjust for
capital gains and losses,
as I said, on the balance sheet.
And you end up with a net
balance sheet position.
So you see you're
going from flows
into changes in the stocks
into the new balance sheet.
You have assets.
You use assets in production.
You get the flow, et cetera.
Inventory-- that was asked about
earlier-- is an example, again,
of distinguishing
inputs in production
from ways of savings.
So this is the integrated
financial accounts.
Unfortunately, it is,
again, not available--
it has errors and
omissions, and it's not
available at the
state or local level.
So now I want to take you
through a series of examples
of other things that
are always in the news,
that you've heard about.
And I'll present those facts
to you and then explain how
the measurement
underlying those, quote,
"well-known facts"
is problematic.
So one, inequality-- and here
I'm drawing on this paper--
Piketty, Saez, and Zucman--
and they're obviously
not the only ones.
The story here is the
top 1% of the population
own 60% of the wealth.
You hear that over
and over again.
So where are these
numbers coming from?
Well, what we have
is quite limited.
These guys start with GDP as
measured by the BEA and so on.
And then they're saying, well,
who actually has part of it?
Who has the shares?
How big are the shares of GDP?
So they want to
create something new,
arguably, called
distributional accounts, which
is the way GDP is distributed
in the population,
saying GDP is fine for
totals, for growth, and so on.
But for inequality,
the aggregates
don't tell us the
degree of inequality.
So people have used different
surveys to measure inequality,
and there's a discrepancy.
So they're saying
that we really need
better distributional accounts.
What fraction of
economic growth accrues
to the bottom 50%
of the population
or the top 10% of
the population?
How much of the rise
in income inequality
is due to the change in labor
share of output versus capital
shares of output?
And even within labor,
what's the dispersion
in labor earnings across
different households
with respect to capital?
What's the rate of
return on capital?
They're complaining here
that we don't have answers
to these questions.
Actually, we don't
even have good answers
to the questions about how much
wealth is being redistributed
through taxes and transfers.
So what do they do?
They make an estimate.
And these guys--
Smith, Zidar, and Zwick--
complain about the estimate,
and they try to do better.
So why are the
estimates unreliable?
Because, as in the
theme of this lecture,
wealth and income are not
independently measured.
They're consistent
with one another
but only in a mechanical way.
How wealthy is a household?
We don't have the wealth.
Let's look at the flows.
Let's look at the income
flows over time the way
we did for that life cycle model
for Thailand, or, for example,
I showed you one
slide for the US.
If you had income
over time and say
they could put it in
the bank, then you
might want to
discount the income
and get the net present value
today of future labor earnings,
like human capital
or flows from assets.
The problem is, how
do you discount it?
What discount rate do you use?
Piketty et al.
are assuming a constant discount
rate across all the households,
despite the obvious
heterogeneity in households--
in particular, despite the fact
that some wealthier households
get income from business
and poorer households don't.
At best, they have
financial income.
But it's usually
wages and so on.
So Zwick basically
adjusts the discount rate.
And they start
changing the numbers.
Basically, the share
of wealth of the top 1%
is different from what
you commonly hear.
The share of wealth of the
top 10% of the population
is a bit different from
what you typically hear,
because they've allowed for
heterogeneity in this discount
rate.
So their estimates
of net worth are
different across these
different groups.
So that's one illustration
of the problems with very
important topical issues.
So much policy work
and politics is
based on perceived measures of
inequality that are actually
not terribly reliable.
I'm not saying
people aren't poor,
and I'm not saying
there's no inequality.
I just wish we had better
quantitative measures of it.
Second application in
this terrible world
we're living in--
COVID-19.
So what is the
impact of COVID-19
on individuals, on groups,
on the entire economy?
Again, the problem
we face in the US--
the data are coming
from different sources.
There's a lot of creativity.
I'll show you what
people have done.
But the bottom line is going
to be, again, the data are not
integrated in the sense
that the income flows are
measured but are not
measured in a way
that would be consistent
with a balance sheet.
In fact, typically, we do not
have both an income statement
and a balance sheet
for anybody in the US.
So here's a great paper--
Chetty and coauthors--
which is the starred paper
on the reading list.
"How Did COVID-19
and Stabilization
Policies Affect Spending
and Employment?"
And then subheader--
"A New Real-Time
Economic Data Tracker."
If you look at the paper,
you'll see the WWW dot.
You can click on
it, and you'll start
seeing a lot of geography.
So this is a summary of
what they're finding.
And I should tell you, this
and all the other slides
are based on what was going
on in the US post-March,
April, the first surge,
and not the surge that
took place early in the summer
and not the current mess.
So what they find is that
high-income individuals reduced
spending in mid-March,
particularly in areas
that had high COVID
infection rates,
and particularly in
sectors associated
with physical interaction.
So the reduction in
spending of the individuals
hurt businesses that catered
to high-income individuals,
namely, small businesses
in affluent zip codes,
like restaurants and so on.
They laid off their
employees, who
tend to be low-income
individuals, which
is where we got the surge
in unemployment, initially
in affluent areas.
You can see the
local diversity here.
So they go on to use an
event study to then estimate
the impact of policies
that were supposed
to mitigate the adverse impact.
States varied in
reopening, as you know.
And, nevertheless, it
didn't have a lot of impact
on local employment.
Stimulus payments to
households were made.
That did increase
consumer spending,
but again, had very little
impact on employment
because, obviously, you
don't take the check
and go buy something at risk
in a shop that may be closed.
At best, you're going
to spend it on--
I'll get to the spending
and saving momentarily.
In particular, this
Paycheck Protection Program,
which is in the news again
today because the BEA is under--
SBA is under scrutiny--
those loans had
little impact on employment
in small businesses.
So I don't know.
If you're macro-oriented,
you might think,
that's an increase in spending.
It should affect
aggregate demand.
It should have shown up
as increased employment.
But it didn't.
This is a study from
the Philadelphia Fed.
And they used payments
transection data,
called Fiserv.
So this is related to
credit/debit card transactions,
but it's not Visa data.
It's actually the
processing company
that puts devices out there so
you can swipe your credit card
and send a communication
from the store to the bank.
Those transactions data are
available on Fiserv in the US.
And the Philadelphia Fed study
is consistent with Chetty
and so on in the sense that
spending on restaurants
and lodgings went down.
And instead, people started
spending money at home
on home improvement,
some people.
So this is, again, the
story of heterogeneity.
Some people were able,
as essential workers,
to keep working on site.
Not much shows up for
their spending differences.
Some start working remotely,
but they're still working.
Their expenditures
are pretty much
proportional to their income,
not terribly surprisingly.
You have people who were
laid off and furloughed.
They're not getting
income anymore.
And the expenditures
drop more for the people
who had been earning
the least income.
So there's a big
drop in expenditures
to vulnerable people,
people who had low income
to begin with-- more on the
balance sheet momentarily.
Now, one potential
limitation of these data
is they're electronic
transactions, obviously.
Well, what about currency?
Well, you might
think, oh, come on.
That's not a big deal.
It is a big deal.
In the US, roughly
25% of transactions
are still accounted
for by paper currency.
And then, mystery
of all mysteries, it
skyrocketed upwards.
And that's not just
a US phenomenon.
So it's kind of perplexing.
You would think paper currency
is pretty dirty stuff.
You're exposed to the virus,
handling other people's-- you
eventually get their
money and so on.
Some people take
it home at night
and wash it because they don't
want to be infected by it.
But they seem to be doing stuff
that's requiring more of it
because currency outstanding,
as measured by the Federal
Reserve, has gone way up.
And there's a shortage of
coins in the US right now.
So we don't know why.
And it also makes
the measurement
under Fiserv a little trickier.
This would not be
true with Alipay
in China because they got
all the transactions data--
maybe we'll get
back to that later.
What about lower-income
households?
So here's another study
by Baker and co-authors
on income and liquidity.
Now, this is kind
of interesting.
They're looking at the
marginal propensity
to consume out of the
stimulus payments.
They made friends with
a not-for-profit company
called SaverLife, helping
working families previously
for the virus,
helping those families
to develop better savings habits
and to meet financial goals.
This reminds me a lot of what
we were doing in Thailand.
In particular, they had
individuals link there
voluntarily--
if they chose to do it, link
their accounts to SaverLife.
So now SaverLife has access to
their bank account information
to see the transactions
and the balance sheets.
You see where I'm
going with this.
So now you can finally, for this
special subset of households,
see inflows and outflows.
I guess I misspoke a minute ago
when I said it's never done.
This is an instance where we
have a version of the income
statement and a version
of the balance sheet,
at least for some
of the line items.
What happened with
the stimulus payments?
As soon as they get the money,
they spend it within 10 days.
And they spend it on food and
nondurables, pay the rent--
that's in the news again lately.
So you get a picture of
relatively poor households.
Not only that, they looked
at the balance sheet
to see how much, quote,
"liquidity" households had.
And the lower the liquid
stuff in the balance sheet,
the larger their marginal
propensity to consume out
of the stimulus payment.
So this looks like households
that have a pretty lean balance
sheet.
They do not have
a lot of assets.
They certainly don't
have liquid assets.
So then they have
been saving very much.
And when they get that stimulus
payment, they spend it.
So they must have been
cutting back on expenditures,
at least before they got
the stimulus payment.
And, likewise, they
didn't seem to save it.
They could have taken the
income transfer and put it
into their savings account.
But they didn't.
By and large, they spent it.
Well, it makes sense
if you're poor,
and you don't have
liquid assets,
and you've lost your income.
But then you come
to this other study.
This is JPMorgan, the bank,
using their own internal data
on household accounts
held by JPMorgan.
And they have an institute
that does research.
So they're reporting here on the
spending of various households,
including low-income households.
And they find large
increases in liquid assets
for almost all
households, including
these low-income households.
That's exactly the opposite
of what Baker found.
So it's a bit of a puzzle.
Now, granted, it's
a different sample.
It doesn't mean that one is
wrong and the other is right.
But it certainly
shows you that we're
getting very mixed
pictures here,
because these are
among the very few ways
that you can join
the stocks and flows.
You can get the
income and balance
sheet for customers of
JPMorgan if you construct it,
as these guys did.
And you can get
it for SaverLife,
which is the data that Baker
and company were using.
They also looked at
small businesses.
And they find cash balances
in JPMorgan accounts
of small businesses
decreased when COVID arrived
and decreased more in
some cities than others
and decreased more
for certain sectors
and for certain ethnicities.
So, again,
restaurants hit hard--
Asian-owned firms actually
hugely hit, even more
than Black firms, which,
in turn, were hit harder
than white-operated businesses.
So businesses are hurting.
Some people think
small businesses--
small and medium
enterprises are the backbone
of the US and many economies.
And so the adverse impact of
COVID hits hard on the economy
when it hits these businesses.
So then you would hope
this Paycheck Protection
Program would have helped.
So the Paycheck PPP
Program passed by Congress
allowed the Treasury
to fund loans
through the Small
Business Administration.
SBA loans in the US are
for small businesses.
They're 85% guaranteed loans.
But they're initiated
by commercial banks.
So in order to
get access to PPP,
you essentially
already had to have
some relationship with a bank.
So, in the end,
who got the money?
People that had bank accounts
in relationship banking.
This picture struck
me this morning
when I was reviewing
before class
because these red areas
in March and April
were pretty much
low-virus areas.
Of course, nowadays, today,
everything is reversed.
And this is where
the current surge is.
But it was not
like this in March.
Instead, it was
New York, remember?
Well, New York didn't get
very many of these PPP loans.
So the loans went--
so it's a complaint, yes.
It's also a comment on the
physical infrastructure.
Because we don't have
good measurement,
we also didn't have a good way
of getting purchasing power
into the hands of those
small businesses that
really needed the liquidity.
So, to bring all
these pieces together,
we need better data in the US.
The US doesn't have
surveys like what
I had shown you for Thailand.
And, likewise, there
is payments data--
I was alluding to it--
Scott Schuh was
at the Boston Fed,
and they were
collecting surveys.
That's how we know how many
people use currency in the US.
So I've teamed up with Scott.
And we're making plans
to basically collect data
like we collected in Thailand.
Scott moved from Boston
to West Virginia.
He's at the University
of West Virginia.
That's a deliberate
choice because that's
an obvious area--
West Virginia being a
relatively poor state
in the United States.
And that's basically
what we hope
will be the starting point.
So we have in mind here an
ambitious multiyear research
program, where we're going
to be collecting data
according to best practices.
Part of it is going to combine
the Boston Fed payment surveys
with my surveys from Thailand.
But part of it is we're
not going to collect it
all with physical surveys.
We want to get the
electronic data.
So we will go to the
households and so on
and try to get
permission the way
Baker et al. did to access
the electronic data for bank
account and payroll
information, assuming
that's the way they get paid.
So we'll run a survey to
see whether households
are willing to share
this data with us or not
and figure out the best
method, and then collect it,
very mindful of the
financial accounts.
So we'll be using the
framework of integrated
financial accounts, linking
the balance sheet to the income
statement and running
checks all the while
so that we have as good of a
survey with as few errors as
possible.
I wish we were a little bit
further along with this.
But I'll just say that if
any of you are interested,
let me know, because there
is a lot of work to do.
But, actually,
nowadays, traveling
isn't very easy either.
But my heart is in
this enterprise.
So that's all for today.
This is kind of the
state of data in the US.
And I've chosen to do this
by looking at 3 topics--
one, what we did in Thailand,
which is local economies--
in this case, states in the US--
looking at it through the lens
of balance sheets and income
statements if possible,
although struggling
because we don't have the
data collected that way,
and then looking at the
impact of trade shocks
and state-level
balance of payments.
The second was
measures of inequality
and how we wish
they were better.
And the third-- the impact
of the virus, which, again,
runs into the same limitations.
Questions?
OK.
So that completes the second of
the two applications of trade
for Thailand in the US, back
to the two-by-two-by-two.
And then we'll gear up for
a review of the material
that we've covered
since the last midterm.
We'll do that next Tuesday.
And you can start on
Friday with Michael.
So that's all for today.
Thank you so much.